un camion de déménagement renversé et
après une course folle dans les rues du
centre ville
preuve que le terrorisme peut frapper
partout même au coeur de l'alberta lui
seul 17 hommes je pensais que la
prochaine attaque serait à tokyo à los
angeles mais pas ici
samedi en début de soirée un homme au
volant de cette chevrolet blanche fonce
dans un barrage policier à l'extérieur
du stade de football
il frappe ensuite un agent un coup de
couteau avant de prendre la fuite
laissant par le drapeau du groupe armé
état islamique dans son véhicule
les images difficiles à regarder pour le
maire quelques heures plus tard les
policiers retrouvent le suspect au
volant d'un camion de déménagement le
poursuivre le long de l'avenue jasper
l'une des artères les plus achalandées
menten le camion frappent quatre piétons
avant de se renverser
on apercevait 10 20 voitures de police
foncer à toute allure derrière le camion
je n'avais jamais vu ça explique ce
résident qui a pu observer la scène de
chez lui le suspect abdulahi hasan
sharif un réfugié somalien de 30 ans qui
habitait dans ce logement était connu
des autorités en 2015 nous avons reçu
une plainte parce qu'il aurait tenu des
propos extrémistes explique la grc qui
n'avait pas suffisamment de preuves pour
l'accusé ce spécialiste des questions de
défense et sécurité et lui n'est pas
surpris edmonton en fait avait déjà été
identifié par le canadien comme l'inde
est l'un des terreaux fertiles pour des
attentats terroristes au canada
essentiellement parce qu'on a une large
diversité de communautés qui fait en
sorte que c'est plus facile de
radicaliser les jeunes malgré tout la
première ministre de l'alberta se veut
rassurante et de production décède y as
they do if we hate des résidents des
menten peuvent se sentir en sécurité dit
elle pour l'instant le ministre fédéral
la sécurité publique doivent goudé on ne
juge pas nécessaire d'augmenter le
niveau d' alerte au pays
les autorités croient qu'il s'agit
d'actes isolés commis par un loup
solitaire qui maintenant entre les mains
des forces de l'ordre
ici leur enceinte et radio canada
edmonton